Hello everyone and welcome back to the
channel. I appreciate all the support on
last week's video. Uh but we're going to
get back into systems design for the
time being. So, uh that means I've got
about six more weeks or so of retaining
your guys respect uh until I actually
code for the first time on this channel
and everyone realizes that I'm a
terrible engineer. So, while I have your
attention, in the meantime, let's go
ahead and talk about Yelp. Yelp is an
app that allows you to review local
businesses. This way, you can see
ratings of various stores in your
neighborhood. For example, I run a
massage parlor, and it has many
five-star reviews. Yelp typically
operates on a location basis. When you
enter the website, it'll show you places
within a certain radius of a point. That
being said, it also exposes the ability
to perform searches for businesses by
their name. Let's formally outline these
requirements. This problem is relatively
simple in terms of its main objectives.
The first one is that we can create an
entry for a local business. We just need
to provide that business's name,
address, and a photo of it. From there,
other users should be able to leave
reviews for that business. Each review
can leave a rating number out of five
and a text body expressing how they felt
about the service they received. It
should also be the case that when a user
selects a given business, they should be
able to load all of the reviews people
have left on it. Finally, we need to be
able to search for businesses. The first
search functionality is locationbased. A
user can enter an address and see all
the places within a certain number of
miles from their location. The second
way of searching is textbased. A user
enters a search term and sees all
relevant businesses on the site.
According to some estimates that I see
on the internet, Yelp contains listings
for tens of millions of local
businesses. Just to be conservative,
let's have our site support 100 million
of them. To actually store the data for
a listing, we need to store some
location information, a name, a link to
a photo, and maybe a bit of metadata. We
can conservatively call this 1 kilob of
information. That means that our entire
table of listings is just 100 GB in size
and can comfortably fit on a single
server. Additionally, Yelp has reported
that they have 30 million monthly active
users. If all of those happen to make
one query a day on average, that's 30
million queries per day and around 350
per second. Depending on the complexity
of the query, it's possible that a
particularly beefy single database could
handle this throughput. But in the event
that it can't, we'll also discuss ways
to increase the amount of throughput we
can handle. As we mentioned, the
entirety of our small business listing
database can fit on a single node. Let's
map out an initial schema and update it
as we go. A first pass at a table schema
could be ID, name, latitude, longitude,
thumbnail URL. We also need to create a
schema for a reviews table. This could
be ID, listing ID, poster ID, post
creation timestamp, number of stars, and
text content. It seems like for our
listings table, we want an index on the
ID. For our reviews table, it's
important that we're able to find
reviews by their listing ID quickly. In
this case, we likely want an index on
the listing ID and within each listing,
an internal sort on the postcreation
timestamp. In the event that our reviews
table gets too large, we can shard it.
We just want to ensure that all reviews
from each listing stay on the same shard
for fast lookups when looking at a given
listing. We can use the listing ID as
the shard key. Recall that we want to be
able to perform searches based on a
listing name. A really naive approach
here would be to create a secondary
index based on those names. The problem
with this is that if we want fuzzy text
matching or to allow searching for a
term that is just one word in the whole
name of a listing, we wouldn't gain any
efficiency improvements. The proper
technique for performing text search is
to use a search engine which is based on
an inverted index. An inverted index
allows us to map the tokens in the text
of each listing back to a listing ID.
This way, if a search matches any of
those terms, we can quickly figure out
all of the relevant listings. We can
even go beyond creating an inverted
index on just the listing names. Perhaps
there are additional descriptors or tags
we can add to the listings like Mexican
food or footrev from Jordan.
Fortunately, this is functionality that
certain databases natively support. In
Postgress, for example, you can tokenize
text columns with a TS vector and then
create a GIN or generalizable inverted
index on top of that. Now you can easily
perform text search matching on the
data. Often times developers will choose
to use separate systems for their text
searching needs. One common example here
is elastic search. However, given that
we're just using a single node for our
system, we can keep things simple and
keep it all in a Postgress table.
Elastic search is built on top of a
search engine called Lucine, which I've
spoken about more in my concept series.
I'll link a video about that in the
description. Let's move on to talking
about geographic search. How can we
figure out all locations that are within
a certain distance from a given address?
To start, we first need a way of
translating an address to a latitude and
longitude pair. Fortunately, there are
many services that do this for us. One
example is the Google Maps geocoding
API. Once we have our latitude and
longitude pair for a user, we need to
find the listings near them. The most
naive option would be to run a linear
scan through our database and manually
check whether the latitude and longitude
values are close enough in each row.
That's silly though, as it's linear to
the size of the table. Even though it's
not a gigantic table, you don't want to
have to read hundreds of gigabytes of
data for every one of these queries.
What if instead we put an index on our
latitude value and then our longitude
value within that? You may think that
this would allow us to efficiently find
all points within a boundary of
latitudes and longitudes. But it doesn't
really. Consider the fact that when you
make an index with two fields, you sort
by the first and then within each value
for the first, you sort by the second.
For example, if we want to find all
locations close to latitude value 100
and longitude value 100, we'll first
find all rows with latitude 95 to 105.
However, when it comes time to filter
down our remaining values, we can't
really do this very efficiently. This is
because latitudes are a continuous
numeric value and there are going to be
very few points that share identical
latitudes. Instead, we'll end up
basically doing a linear scan over all
the points within our latitude range,
which is expensive. The common way to
solve a problem like this is with
something known as geospatial indexing.
A geospatial index typically attaches a
single value to each row which is called
a geohash. The idea behind the geohash
is that all points that are close to one
another have very similar hashes. This
way if we want to find all locations
near a given point, we just look at the
closest geohash values to it. If we
index the data by the geohash value,
this becomes a very efficient search
since geohash values that are next to
one another in sorted order are in very
similar locations. Under the hood, this
can be implemented in many different
ways. One common implementation is
something known as a quad tree, which
recursively divides a 2D plane into four
boxes. Each child box has the same
geohash as its parent plus an additional
number between 0 and three. The image on
screen represents these in binary. This
way, very small boxes that are next to
one another have super similar
geohashes. This property is retained
even when these boxes only encompass a
few meters in size. In practice, this
isn't something that we want to
implement ourselves. Yet again,
Postgress has an extension for it known
as PostGis.
We can now use geography points in each
of our listings and then create a
secondary index on them. Now, we can run
really fast queries to determine all of
the places closest to a given user.
Behind the scenes, Postgress chooses an
appropriately sized outer bounding box
to begin filtering down points to
consider and then checks the exact
latitudes and longitudes to see if
they're actually within the distance we
specified in our query. Note that all
points within a bounding box have a
geohash that starts with the ID of that
outer box. So to find those, we can run
a range query from the geohash of the
box that we care about until the geohash
of the next box. Having an index on
these geohash values makes this very
efficient. Keep in mind that up to this
point we've basically said that our
listings table wouldn't be sharted. That
makes life very easy for us. But if we
don't partition it, our single node has
to bear the entirety of the workload for
our application. Besides that, we do
need to ensure some fault tolerance if
our node goes down. We can run our
Postgress database with many readonly
replicas. Since we don't really care
about data steness for the listings
table, this should be totally okay.
Since the amount of new listings being
added is fairly small, we should be fine
to have our primary node replicating the
data to many places at a time. The
majority of Yelp users are just going to
be lurking and looking at business
reviews without actually leaving any of
their own. The number of reads on a site
like Yelp should largely outnumber the
number of writes. Therefore, we want
these to be as fast as possible. We can
help achieve this, especially for
popular searches, with caching. we can
cache both our search term results as
well as our location-based results. On
the location-based results side, every
client is in a slightly different
position. So, in theory, we'd probably
never get a cache hit. Perhaps what we
could do instead is have each client
that's in the same zip code search for
results from the same starting latitude
and longitude. This way, a user in the
same zip code would be able to fetch
results from the cache if somebody else
made a search just before from the same
zip code. Like with many of our other
caches, we can use an LRU replacement
policy here since we don't know what
will be useful to cache in advance. We
can cache reviews for popular listings.
Also, the first piece of all of this is
being able to create a listing from the
administrative side of the application.
To do so, a user hits an endpoint that
processes all relevant information and
creates an entry in the listings table.
From there, our listings database
creates a primary index on the listing
ID, a secondary index on a geohash of
the listing, and another local secondary
inverted index on the relevant search
terms. When a user wants to add a
review, it gets sent to the database.
The reviews table is sharded on the
listing ID to quickly fetch all reviews
for a given listing. If a user wants to
see businesses near them or find
businesses with search terms, they'll
once again hit the listing database or
one of its replicas. Ideally though, the
result is stored in a cache. To keep
things simple, we can use look aside
caching here. If the result is cached,
we'll return it back to the user.
Otherwise, we fetch the result from the
database, place it in the cache, and
return back to the user. Ultimately, the
design for this video is pretty simple
because we get to rely on having a
single listings database node. If we
couldn't do this, we'd have to worry
about sharding out both a geospatial
index as well as a search index. These
are topics that are worthy of their own
videos. For the sake of Yelp, let's
consider a different challenge. When
showing listing previews, either from a
location-based search or a term-based
search, we want to show an average
number of stars that they've received in
their reviews. Let's discuss how to do
that. To compute a business's score, we
can take the average of the scores that
it received during its reviews. This is
super easy to do by just storing a total
number of reviews and total sum of all
scores per listing. When showing the
average score, we just divide the sum of
all review scores by the number of
reviews. As we've discussed in many
other videos, the naive way to implement
this would be to do a transactional
write when creating each review. While
this may be good enough, it could
require a distributed transaction if we
have to shard out our reviews table to
be on a different node than our listings
table. We've discussed in depth why we
don't like these. The next option would
be to run a nightly batch job on the
reviews table to compute the average
score of each listing and then update
the listing table with those results.
This works too, but can be pretty
wasteful from a compute perspective if
the majority of listings don't receive
new reviews in a given day. Instead, we
can use our typical workflow of change
data capture. When a review is created,
we'll place it in Kafka and then
eventually incorporate it into our
listing preview. Given we're talking
about Kafka here, there's a possibility
that we end up replaying a review and
accidentally counting it twice. While
this isn't the end of the world, we can
protect against it by storing the last
scene review creation timestamp in the
listing row itself and checking if the
incoming reviews creation timestamp is
larger than that. This works because
Kafka should be delivering us the
reviews in order of their creation time.
Though, it is notable that this may be
buggy in the event that the review
creation timestamps are skewed for some
reason. Since there aren't that many
reviews incoming, this system should
save us in the majority of cases. Thank
you all for sticking around the video.
Hopefully, a nice little introduction to
how location-based indexing works, as
well as a little bit of search indexing
as well. Uh we're going to expand upon
this a little bit next week when we talk
about Uber.